yeah i would say molecular sodomy is a
field of science um I I would I would I
would say it's probably a lumped under
chemistry maybe because cooking while it
has certainly biology and some physics
it's mostly chemistry but molecular
gastronomy was a term coined by
scientists to describe the work that
they were doing in an effort to
understand what's happening to to the
food that we eat are the food that we
cook I'm sorry what's happening to food
as we cook it as we put it through a
myriad of physical mechanical processes
people like Harold McGee and Nicholas
kurti Nicholas kurti is one of the
scientists that coined the term along
with Harold hair VTS and some other
people and i believe it was kurti who
famously said we know more about what's
going on on the surface of the moon then
inside a souffle and that's again I
can't weigh on whether or not that's
true because I don't know how much we
know about about either but uh I I think
it was a group of people that were
curious to understand what makes us
souffle rise one of the mechanics what's
happening whatwhat's let's pick it apart
and understand it and and I think that a
large number of Chef certainly myself
included found that field of study very
not only very interesting but useful so
we're we've been for probably the last
15 years or so trying to avail ourselves
to the information that these people are
generating along along with generating
our own and some others and other
outside sources that are that are maybe
not food scientists per se um and take
that take that information and and and
use it to learn more about what we're
doing to understand how to cook to
understand what's happening to food as
we cook it in an effort I think to be
better cooks
well we have learned a lot i would i
would say that in the last uh the last
15 years you know plus or minus five
we've learned more about cooking than we
have in the 15,000 prior 15,000 years
prior to that and i think that that
makes that's exciting to me and i think
that makes for an exciting time to be
cooking for anyone for any curious cook
for anyone who desires to understand
more what's happening to a chicken when
you roast it or a vegetable when you
blanch or a fish when you poach it in an
effort to cook it better and to cook it
in a more informed way because again uh
like taste their subjectivity in cooking
as well and I think that that's good
because there's no right way necessarily
to cook something but understanding
what's happening to it up any given
object while you're cooking it allows
you to make an informed decision about
how to cook it and again I like the fact
that there's no right or wrong way to
poach an egg but knowing what's
happening to an egg as it goes from 60
degrees Celsius to 70 degrees Celsius
helps you make the decisions about at
what point you want to start or stop the
cooking and and that I find really
really very fascinating because to me
knowing mechanically how to how to poach
an egg but not not what's happening to
it while it's poaching is almost an
empty knowledge it's not it's not as
useful as as knowing okay the egg white
proteins are coagulating at this
temperature and the yolks are our
coagulating that temperature and so I
can control this in that and knowing the
variables and understanding the
variables I think it makes anybody a
better cook